the man to my right who has been
hilarious joining Silicon Valley right
in the middle of season 4 and you can
check him out in the upcoming Hulu
series with the produced of a Seth Rogen
produced news show future man and also
OSS on Amazon good to see you Haley Joel
Osment to see you too man
you bet so let me ask you this question
you are a Laker fan I am what is your
stance on the ball family as they have a
big scenario coming up in two days from
now yeah I mean I'm my draft IQ isn't
great I heard there was some second
thoughts about him after the workout but
now it seems to be leaning back towards
their going to take it well just in
terms of dad and I mean having been
around sets and I'm sure parents and the
way things that happen in how parents
could be helicopter parents right yeah
what do you what do you would you want
this it's a new scenario let's put it
this way would you want the scenario to
be brought upon the Lakers or involved
with the Lakers or to go on some
completely different unnamed person who
might have similar talent just bring
that play I hope they go for the for the
you know the best guy they can find when
it comes to his dad and everything one
thing I did read was that at UCLA he
seemed to not be a distraction in all at
least at the game there so yeah you
don't want off the court distractions
but if he's the best player and it
doesn't seem like he's fazed by his
particular relationship with the media
like yeah we have an exciting time
coming up because they I think what Paul
George is saying that he wants to give
the order that could be pretty awesome
LeBron's a long shot but after the
firing yesterday it's like who knows
maybe nose please come to LA LeBron well
I'm Matt Jackson charge yeah and now
Magic's in in the spot would when did
you first start loving the Lakers
oh god my mom when she moved to LA when
my parents was LA in the mid 80s you
know it's a great era for the Lakers big
basketball fan and yeah just growing up
that was the team magic was a you know a
great player I was really into her yeah
and then we were you're kind of spoiled
as a fan and you know childhood and
adulthood with five or six championships
and
you know in the years that I've been
watching them so but the Dodgers are
your team yeah and that one's going to
be the most special I think if we do get
a championship because that's the one
team of all the teams I like that has
not done it in my lifetime they got one
in 1988 the year I was born
so you were born the year Kirk Gibson
what yard on Dennis ugh that's right
yeah and that one we had this tradition
a lot of my friends from high school and
I we go to spring training each year and
the year the month leading up to going
out to Camelback we do an advent
calendar so each person it cycles and
does like a little moment number one is
always the Kurt Gibson home run that
like gets us into the season you know I
mean I was at an event last Friday for
Al Michaels and he was honored here in
town and the person who spoke and
honored him last was Ben Scully
oh man yeah right and and he he stepped
up to the podium and his first words in
front of the whole crowd was good
afternoon a very very pleasant good
afternoon to everybody today and the
whole place just went yeah eight and
then he just paused and he goes you know
I've been waiting so many months to say
that having said that this year this
felt really really good just to see him
and yeah just to hear his voice its
rattle is gonna be missed you know I I I
really like what Joe Davis is doing we
have you know shorts been great but yeah
that's what you associate with baseball
and being a Dodger fan additionally like
yeah he's the greatest sports caster of
all time it's kind of difficult though
and I say this with a Maricopa as a
Yankee fan and brockman is a Boston Red
Sox guy and we did the math that the Red
Sox are spending just only 200,000 fewer
dollars in the Yankees on their payroll
outfit but they're all who's counting
far outpaced by as I point out the
luckiest quarter billion roster yeah yes
we like the Colossus but we're pretty
likable I think you don't yeah I have a
kind of you know they scrap their way
with a quarter billion dollars worth of
talent yeah oh yeah and surviving the
the terrible injuries we had all last
season and having guys like Cody
Bellinger come up and you know the the
youth on the team and the whole attitude
that's been there since Dave Roberts
came in is just really fun as a fan the
fact that say that that tweed could have
gone completely south last year
that we not learning good and now it's
like well they said him to Oklahoma City
now I know he's in the birds to the
people in Detroit you know and got a
game suspension for that one I mean the
fact that they kind of redeemed him in a
way so did you where did where did you
take in the playoffs oh I was shooting
Oasis in South Africa during our whole
playoff run and I had adjusted my
schedule so that I'd get home from work
at like Oh in Cape Town in South Africa
I don't know if I said that so it's like
12 hours ahead or something and I nine
hours dad I would go to sleep at 7:00 or
8:00 at night as soon as I got home from
work wake up at 3 o'clock the morning
watch the playoff games and go to work
at 7 or 8 and the Kershaw saved in Game
five against the Nationals went for like
more than 5 hours so I like had to leave
the moment he was going to do it I was
like I have to had the door to the hotel
room open and he's boarded and you go to
work I was like why are you so upset and
I'm like no I'm happy I'm a little like
yeah that was intense yes all with the
save last year oh man yeah
and it's I mean with what can we did to
set that up and you know then bringing
back Justin Turner and kenley jansen
it's just a such a lovable team so it
fires a dedication so who's got the more
aggressive beard Justin Turner you or
Chris law at the Chris command center
your brothers and beards over there I
think we're a very respectable territory
right here yeah as you saw in the
Silicon Valley clip I sort of trim mine
down a little bit I got to give it to
Justin because you know he had you know
he hits like a monster yeah so you give
it I've got Haley Joel Osment here in
the Rich Eisen show like to take a
60-second break we'll come back and I
want to talk about your your your career
a little bit more it kind of didn't hit
that last time you were here a couple of
years ago and also just your your your
sense if you will that's no pun intended
I guess in a way about spoiler alerts
there and what where you stand on that
subject because we go back and forth on
whether or not you need to stay mom
about a movie or a television show that
Haley Joel Osment here on the Rich Eisen
show back in 60 seconds
[Music]
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show I've
got Haley Joel Osment here in studio
Silicon Valley what a funny funny show
and Alec Byrd who is a long long time
associative of Dave Mandel who does
dangerous a for who we know here on the
show does the league and Curb Your
Enthusiasm and Seinfeld from back in the
day
Claire Reza said I know right I mean so
now you're involved in the show where
does this rank in terms of experiences
for you
professionally way up there and yeah
it's just everybody behind the camera
and like judge and everything and then
also as I asked of guys that are so
talented in all these different areas of
great stand-ups and great improv guys
like it's something that could be very
nerve-wracking going into but as I also
saw like when we do did spoil as a
Babylon like you didn't see is like
Kristen Wiig and these people and the
thing they all have in common is great
improvisers and great performers make
you feel comfortable by how good they
all right that it's it's a playful
atmosphere that you feel like you can
plug into really easily and that was
true and that's again on HBO 10:00 p.m.
Eastern Time and then you know that back
to back with veep is just you know your
your sides are splitting for for 60
solid minutes yeah we got Haley Joel
Osment Stu you what was your first gig
what was your first professional acting
oh yeah what age of Pizza Hut commercial
in probably 1992 I would guess like a
total random your five-year-old kid four
years old yeah they add a a an Ikea they
were taking Polaroids of kids coming in
with their moms which sounds odd it was
two nice women from a casting agency but
they were taking Polaroids of the kids
nowadays I would compare to a Russian
stranger-danger I can now increase but
yeah just got called in did that
commercial and then what were you doing
just eating peeps I say they would be an
understatement and a montage of things
that were it was the Bigfoot Pizza
promotion okay they're doing like a
shaky cam thing about like the Bigfoot
monster right yeah I don't remember the
pizza being very good but by chance the
casting director for Forrest Gump saw
that commercial called me in and then by
a couple months later we were shooting
for his god I mean what was that
experience like pretty crazy
I remember it well because it's so
different from you know your previous
life as a kid like I learned to tie my
shoes on that
and you know we're to teach you how to
talk no no I invited dad night with the
holiday and in Buford I remember sitting
on the stairs outside I should wrap it
around the tree and all that but yeah
just seeing the gunk house and they were
doing the Vietnam stuff they shot that
in South Carolina as well I think so you
have these warehouses of the military
uniforms I'm never walking through there
with Gary Sinise and yeah just a really
crazy time at that scene where forest
learns who you are is one of the most
moving see I mean I mean it always gets
me you know father-son stuff always gets
me that's to me what always makes us a
good sports movie too is the father-son
stuff yeah you know these jamokes I just
found out didn't really learn what the
natural they've never seen the natural
data table real character and Hoosiers
yeah exactly by the way that's what I
mean the father-son stuff is what always
and clearly you know right I like to
fight on the Friday Night Lights and
then we want wire it just flew out of my
heart veto the Kevin Costner movie at
the corn what the hell's but o killed
again do you know I mean a father-son
stuff with Field of Dreams yeah
now that moment with Forrest and you tom
is pretty amazing yeah well I mean and
you too and then of course you know your
mom Claire underwood yeah use your
president yes Porter alert and then okay
weeks ago okay see now back it's the
point I wanted to ask you here because
you know you and Sixth Sense I don't I
don't really want to spoil it but at
this point in time do you think it's
fine for us to talk about something like
that it's complicated I try to be a do
no harm with that kind of stuff yes um
with tweets and stuff like about Game of
Thrones and it's happening I guess I
don't think a movie like The Sixth Sense
would have had the same impact today
though because it probably woulda leaked
before it ever came out the ad strategy
would have been different and now it's
just there was an attitude at the time
that you read about where people enjoyed
taking friends and family didn't know
and having that secret knowledge going
into the movie where now it seems more
like people going like you know
wanting to get the word I remember on
some AOL chat room I remember it was
reported some guy was like trying to
spread he's saying and somebody's like
you're the person that probably pulled
wings off butterflies like that kind of
thing but yeah it's uh I remember when
the red wedding happened on Game of
Thrones I had not read the books didn't
know anything except those videos of
people reacting coming out and I
remember going like I'm not a big
fantasy guy but if this is as crazy as
it seems I'll be mad if it's spoiled for
me so I just sort of cranked through the
first three seasons in like a month and
managed to get all those surprises about
having them spoil so then what is what
is the statute of limitations on
something like Game of Thrones well I
didn't see better call Saul last night
so I've been like so what it looking at
the internet too much today
okay so then so then what would he say
but if if you were on say tomorrow show
would it be fair game I feel a wee do
you think we've been giving somebody an
extra weekend is probably fair but
unrealistic but I think that's probably
Aaron Rodgers beta we said for season
finale it's on you that if you don't
watch it live now too bad but for
regular TV show 24 hours right well it's
interesting because with streaming and
everything has taken away the experience
of everyone sitting down to watch
Seinfeld at the same time or stuff like
that but you know huge endings and
finales and spoiler stuff is are now
sort of bringing us back to that where I
have to watch Game of Thrones on Sunday
night I have to do all that it's going
to be spoiled for me the next day Haley
Joel Osment on the Rich Eisen show what
about a sports blackout do you do sports
Bronco this is something because my dad
only cares about the Falcons so on
Sundays like I'm in LA like we'll watch
football together he doesn't do fantasy
or anything but I do think see football
so I can't wait until the afternoon I
have to be doing all that seems like
I'll record the game we could do it like
later thing I'm sorry I can't I have to
be on it like 10:00 a.m.
like there's no recording of football no
no I can't do that now so what is your
fantasy team game uh if we have a thing
where we switch them all the time it's
our you know it's a lot of people living
in different parts of the country so
it's our way to like mess with each
other okay I can't even remember is
everyone safe for work again well
there's not a whole lot of safe one okay
it's a great league I've only come in
second in the last seven years so you've
never won you're never won the same guy
has won like five times
maybe you should DVR your football games
just to switch you know maybe yeah just
throw darts at the board or something
sometimes random chance but yeah yeah I
I had to UM the year
Michigan played Louisville for the
national championships of 2013 was the
last time I attempted sports blackout
yeah and because I was flying back with
a family vacation yeah the kids and I'm
I'm serious about this stuff so I had my
my kid was five at the time I had him go
into the cockpit of the plane and tell
the pilot to please God and now well I
had actually used him to get into the
cockpit of the plane or this degree not
always annex crowding vestiges of the
pilot I wanted to use like that moment
sort of out of airplane to see if scraps
is a boy dog you know that sort of
moment between the pilot and the kid and
use that moment debate hate would you
mind please yeah don't give any updates
then my wife who knows how nuts I am
walked me through the terminal in LAX
don't look at that TV that TV this Baro
has it on don't look there look straight
ahead we did not put the radio on it all
and then I had uh my wife go into the
our room turn on the TV to make sure you
house the DVRs on alarms when yeah like
the news is on and I guess we one or
more days on the game it stays on the
channel yeah there should be a function
that it changes the channel for you
it has sure that he after the DVR is
over yeah yeah I have congrats so you
saw it without it getting swelled RIA
except for the fact that I just knew I
was going to be disappointed just by
merely being a Michigan fan that's
magnetic waves in the air as you can
just yes sensitive that was if you will
yeah you know right there I have one
spoiler story go we're going going to
see a Knicks game in New York walking
down the concourse right after the
Breaking Bad finale and I had a friend
do it earlier in the day to party
spoiled a death that happens in one of
the last episodes as we're walking on
concrete damn you guys hey remember at
that party when I told you so
died and like dozens of people go ah
that's the problem never heard it in
public you never know where lockout
could be pierced how sensitive he's
being though you're not saying the
person who's definitely years after they
yeah wait are you doing a very good job
this is a man this is the man who saw
dead people you know is that what my
spoiler dnase yes strong yeah well and I
love movies where I didn't see the
trailer I don't like trailers too much
either like my favorite movie going
experiences have been not knowing at all
what's going to happen so I like
disregard for people I was that way with
it would get out I know earthly idea and
I was able to see it on a plane just
three weeks ago so I was able to somehow
some way not have that anytime something
would come up with it I would look the
other way
yeah and had no idea what how it would
be that it would be like a 21st century
Rosemary's Baby with you know yeah
that's a sort of bizarre you know racial
aspect of of Rosemary's Baby that I
didn't come in brilliant movie really a
really even their their billboards
really you know faces it was just like a
house and the words get out like I have
no idea what that's Silicon Valley check
it out um you are in the Amazon pilot
oasis and in future man the upcoming
Hulu series so you're all about the
streaming and and glenne Headly was in
that huh so yeah a last week gets it's a
terrible terrible loss and I didn't get
to know her very well because our
characters don't talk too much on the
show but the few times I met her she was
a very sweet person with an amazing
career well we've been we've been big
fans of yours for for a long time that's
not the royalty I'm including everybody
here at Rich Eisen show set so come back
anytime daily okay Daniel Haley Joel
Osment which is his Twitter handle um
checking out on Twitter and check him
out on Silicon Valley and in Hulu and
Oasis the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience
isn't it amazing you can download an app
with your thumbprint you should download
our app with your thumbprint